[Music]
I've got one more stop to make before I
put my neck on the line to deliver an
authentic Vietnamese menu for my
culinary mentor V I'm feeling nervous
but exciting and a week is a very short
time to get up to speed with something
so magical but where I connect is with
ingredients because they're the hero
understanding them properly will be a
huge advantage going into a challenge
[Music]
I'm heading off the beaten track into
the mountains near my Chow 130
kilometers from Hanoi this is rice paddy
country and I'm here to get my hands on
Venom's most important ingredient and to
learn the wrong choice of rice dishes to
impress people these people one thing
you've got to do first off it's cook
they're right perfectly
today the village are celebrating the
end of the rice harvest with a feast
Sowers the only person in the village
who speaks a bit of English that was
amazing
honestly I felt like Steve McQueen now
and I'm a little bit late okay and the
harvest is finished
come anytime for the feast right yes
those little beauties there this
northern hill tribe not only picked the
rice they process it too but there are
no mod cons here what's going on there
it's fascinating they cut the grace
furious they take all the little rice
grains off the plant and then it's all
swept into the middle of the concrete
yeah
this is incredible yeah mommy that I'm
gonna bite this long in my life yeah I'm
sweating like a Vietnamese Pig is what
all the ladies during the morning
harvest
[Music]
some cameramen sometimes the men look at
risottos in a complete different way now
what's L boy laughing at
hey big boy your turn next
in this 40 degrees heat I think I'd
better stop before I keel over times but
all this rice to good use and learn what
they do with it
and what is this amazing and it's maker
thing and so it's pounded rice yes mix
with water yes what is amazing for me is
the fact that we cook rice one or two
different ways in England you guys
completely different meaning on rice
onions emotion for me to make these
paper-thin rice cakes under the need to
apply a delicate touch sorry
how embarrassing hopefully I could
impress him with my culinary skills my
mix does it fine out to this and I just
don't have it
[Music]
come to me can we come in coming I'm not
gonna screw up anymore John
I'm in danger of busting his chair
started delicious very good I'll buy
some new stools
[Music]
the entire village have gathered to
celebrate the end of the rice harvest as
usual my failed attempt at rice cakes
won't be on offer so I helped to serve
up instead right where do we start with
this fabulous feast
look at this do you take you take the
rice and pass it along and news of my
botched rice paper making has obviously
done the rounds my job what do you think
I do
actor no a doctor I'm a cook
good luck for next year's harvest Cheers
happy harvest I have been useless but
Sowers honored my trip with a gift of
rice from the village thank you I will
do the rice justice okay they treat it
like gold they show it so much respect
they have a huge technical ability to
make rice so fantastic it's it's at a
different level it's been an amazing
week but tomorrow it's crunch time I'll
be in Hanoi to prove to restauranteur a
V that I've cracked Vietnamese cuisine
so lots of things bubbling and festering
away now in my mind and all I need is to
disappear somewhere quiet and just start
nailing down those issues